the power of the dog the moment movie
fans have been waiting for
actors tracy ellis ross and leslie
jordan announcing the nominees for the
94th annual academy awards
sort of a lonesome place out here
she
pete
in the swing of face netflix's western
drama the power of the dog leading the
pack with 12 nominations
including best picture and best director
jane campion becoming the first woman to
be nominated twice
and gain recognition for all of its top
actors
venus and serena gonna shake up this
world
benedict cumberbatch will go
head-to-head for best actor with will
smith who stars in the tennis drama king
richard it's also nominated for best
picture do you know how many world is
ending meetings we've had over the last
two years drought famine hole in the
ozone is so boring another best picture
nominee don't look up is a dark comedy
about a comet headed for earth an
allegory for inaction during the climate
crisis
mommy
family are all gathered in the drawing
room
they are waiting
kristen stewart coming in as a surprise
to some getting her first academy award
nomination for her portrait of princess
diana
other leading ladies contending with her
for best actress include jessica
chastain olivia coleman penelope cruz
and nicole kidman but fans were quick to
notice the lack of diversity
with no woman of color nominated in this
category
there were also some notable snubs
lady gaga not been nominated for house
of gucci people were really excited to
see her get nominated for her second
movie role she did not get nominated
um you have aaron sorkin no nominations
for aaron yes his actors in being the
recorders but not for aaron so you know
it's a mixed bag like it is every year
there are going to be people who are
happy they're going to be people who are
sad and now it's just a matter of
everyone getting out the vote before the
oscar is in march
on the flip side making their way into
some of the higher tier categories were
films from outside the u.s
i think when you look at this year's
nominees you see a much more
international field of nominations drive
my car parallel mothers worst person in
the world flee these are movies that are
outside the united states so it's really
exciting to see that diverse diversity
really amping up in the oscar
nominations save the world the
nominations again proving the power of
streaming giants
netflix with a total of 27 knots
the academy is yet to reveal who will
play host
but there is pressure to put on a show
that resonates with a younger more
diverse audience
when the ceremony takes place at the
dolby theater auditorium in los angeles
for the first time since 2018.
jillian wolf al jazeera